it's a bit cold
maybe that's because of ghosts maybe
because ghosts everywhere huh I know
there is I know darling I know why it's
gonna be okay I know you look at that
look how creepy that is stop being so
creepy my you and might I add
butterflies just shot out of your ass
for no reason at all
oh what's this another diary oh no it's
fluorite okay gonna get you gonna get
you oh give me a give me a big smile
give me a big well come on
I got like none of her I look at the
butt cheek those sticking out of the
wall the gate tell is called haha gazed
on upon the pool Isaac glimpse of ya
will be blinded by the moon please speak
not of them the mouth which I'll just
hand will be made speechless light of
time listen not to the king those who
heed the hour turn heartless by the hey
hello welcome to the party
you're about to die you owe me oh just
gonna dance on the top of the stairs cuz
nobody can stop them me Oh dance mio mio
mio mio mio I need to smoke some herbs
are yummy not to leave you behind and in
the end you left me behind put is having
trouble trusting again he ones creamy
well turn off your phone then
don't kill me don't touch me you're
weird and goopy and you know and yeah
I'm a ghostly essence it spilled out all
over the floor
oh no my actor plus me Oh dad and done
just like that
I'm so good at games
I'm so good at games on the best that
the world has ever seen